Let's see where we end up on this next story.
And who agrees with me and who disagrees with
me.
I hate to say this, but it looks like Democrats
are already blowing the impeachment process
and all but guaranteeing that this is not
going to help them defeat onald Trump in wenty
twenty and I'll explain a, sorry as I hit
my microphone there because I am getting myself
wound up with the story.
I said at the beginning, the impeachment inquiry
is not going to end with onald Trump being
removed from the presidency by a Republican
controlled Senate.
Therefore, the way that the impeachment inquiry
is handled could hurt Trump or it could help
Trump.
Now we've seen the whistleblower complaint.
There is no question that on that alone, in
addition to everything else, an impeachment
inquiry of onald Trump is warranted by the
facts, the facts more than a confirm that
the right move, the correct move based on
what we know is an impeachment inquiry.
The balance is how much do Democrats expose
about Trump's wrongdoing through the inquiry
versus how successfully does onald Trump paint
himself as the victim and the martyr and the
target of, as he likes to say, presidential
harassment.
Democrats are now moving towards the strategy
of narrowing the scope of the impeachment
inquiry to be only about the Trump Biden kraine
fiasco.
Now their idea is don't investigate anything
that onald Trump has done other than the kraine
thing in the impeachment inquiry because it
will shorten the duration of the investigation.
It will let us move to the next steps more
quickly if that's what we want to do.
Obstruction.
They are not going to include self-dealing.
They're not going to include the emen stuff,
which I think is impeachable in and of itself.
That's not going to be part of this investigation.
They are saying Democrats are.
That stuff can still be looked at by individual
house committees.
Uh, but in the mean in the meantime that from
the public eye as part of the impeachment
inquiry is going to completely evaporate.
Nancy Pelosi saying in the meeting they had
yesterday to talk about this quote, this has
clarity and understanding in the eyes of the
American people talking about the kraine story.
If we do articles, meaning if we move forward
with arguing, the president should be removed,
then we can include other things.
Meaning if they decide to go forward with
trying to impeach Trump, they can impeach
for more than just kraine, but the inquiry
should be just about kraine.
I see this as a stunning mistake, a strategic
blunder, ne hundred and ten percent now, I
understand the idea Democrats are not in agreement
about impeaching on obstruction.
Democrats are not in agreement about impeaching
on Amalia mins violations or emen or whatever
else, and the idea is we're all as Democrats.
Nancy Pelosi is saying in agreement about
impeachment over kraine and impeachment inquiry
over kraine.
So let's just focus on that.
But there's a few mistakes in that logic.
The irst mistake is that the truth is Democrats
aren't actually unanimously in agreement on
this.
It is a majority of Democrats in the house
that are in agreement in the same way that
there was a point a few weeks ago or a month
ago where a majority of Democrats seem to
be in agreement with starting an impeachment
inquiry even before you do the kraine thing.
But there are roughly ighteen Democrats that
are not in favor of the impeachment inquiry.
I mentioned earlier in the show that Tulsi
Gabbard is ne of those people who is not in
favor.
So the idea that support for this inquiry
is unanimous is wrong, and it's a false premise
on which the inquiry should be based in decisions
should be made.
So then we get to the econd problem.
The most important thing here is that Republicans
will not vote to remove Trump, uh, via a conviction
in the Senate of the house filing articles
of impeachment.
The whole point of narrowing the scope is
move things along more quickly so that we
could file articles of impeachment sooner
if we decide we want to maybe even this year,
why Republicans aren't going to vote to remove
Trump no matter what.
Now you could argue, well, if the Democrats
do a really good job of exposing Trump's wrongdoing
and they file articles of impeachment and
Republicans still don't vote to remove him,
Republicans will look really bad and it'll
hurt them and Trump in wenty twenty.
I think it's just the wrong calculation.
I think it's the wrong analysis.
I don't think that is based.
In fact, the kraine story is very reasonably
the catalyst for a full impeachment inquiry
starting right now, but I disagree with it
being the sole focus because there is just
so much more here.
The value of this inquiry is expose what Trump
has done and the way to do that is not to
narrow the scope.
Don't put all your eggs in ne basket.
The eggs in ne basket strategy has failed
for Democrats under onald Trump.
Haven't we learned that when Democrats say
this ne thing is going to be devastating to
Trump, it ends up not being devastating to
onald Trump.
I see this as a process, not a bullet.
The kraine thing might look like the bullet,
but it needs to just be a part of a process
that includes financial crimes obstruction,
the emen fiasco.
There is so much more, and I am, I hope I'm,
I don't know if I'm being incorrectly pessimistic.
I want to hear from you.
I'm already losing hope that this entire inquiry
will do anything to help remove onald Trump
in November of wenty twenty I changed my mind
if you believe being incorrectly
pessimistic.
I want to hear from you, but I see already
strategic mistakes being made here.